um who are you a fan of right now that's
just on the come up like help put us on
you know what I'm saying oh I just did a
song with Rika in the Menace I like her
she's from Baltimore she a baddie shout
out to be more anybody out of uh
Northern California you're liking right
now honestly after I drop because I'm
dropping in some more music but I want
to do like a California search for more
female rappers oh dope we don't really
have like a long line of History we've
had girls that came out but I think it's
time to just show
shed more light on the talent of women
in California that's real because like I
mean obviously you're at the Forefront
of that you know there's like Kamaya
back in the day I love me sometimes fire
hella hard super hard that album was
everything she's amazing yes yes uh who
else uh who else is California Lady of
Rage when I was growing up was dope
yeah I don't know forget Day Salon I
like James artist I like herself yeah
she's dope she actually could sing too I
don't know why she don't put the singing
[ __ ] out
um but yeah that that'd be dope maybe
put together like almost like you like a
r project with just like up-and-coming
female I would like to do that that'd be
fire cause I'm producing now I make
beats you're making beats what do you
make beats on
splice splice yeah well you get the
sounds from splice and then I bring it
over where do you bring it over to Pro
Tools or whatever's on the computer I'm
using
I'm still a rookie I just be you know
whatever it sounds like I'll just be
dragging it down well that's what's dope
about splices splice is like a
I feel like a nice entry point into
learning how to produce because you can
kind of like
just type in what sound you're looking
for What BPM you want it's like a candy
store of sounds yeah like do you are you
on there a lot just digging around on
splice do you like put the idea together
and then send it to your producer homie
to like refine it or you like totally
like nah I made the beat I got the
bridge built out here you're not there
yet like so my engineer helps me refine
it nice nice he's hella good what is
your um writing process like um are you
like a lot of people nowadays punch in
do you write down stuff do you got the
phone what do you like how are you
writing um so the last two songs I added
to the single life was memorable in our
reception and what I did is I'll start
the idea in the studio and if like
I feel the energy gets still I'll bounce
it and then I'll go in my car and just
ride around the lake and just like right
wow I write the best in my car
that's dope so you'll just be in your
car just coming up with ideas yeah I
like driving around Rodeo will you do
like a voice note like
yeah because you can't be like riding
while driving I'll have like this phone
with a beat on and then my other phone
recorded me oh wow that's super dope you
gotta be careful out here though man oh
hell we'll see you driving around L.A
too much by yourself shit's [ __ ] up
out here
it is yeah